Speaker 1: All right.
I want to talk about another one of these
horrible incidents.
And listen, every time we have one of these
A.I.M. incidents of assault, and that's really
what it is I talk about, mental illness clearly
seems to be a component with these people.
The woman in this video, which some are calling
an anti mask, Karen, I really am not big on
Karen because it's clearly a racially loaded
term.
It's really applied to white women.
So I stay away from it.
I call this person a really bad person who
also may be mentally ill.
This is another one of these incidents where
a woman in Nebraska, some kind of covid Denyer,
some kind of a.
massacre is repeatedly coughing, coughing,
coughing on the person who is filming.
And we're going to look at this and then we're
going to talk about what crimes may have been
committed here.
So let's start with the story.
This was posted to the Lincoln, Nebraska sub
Reddit a few days ago.
And the person who posted it username Jessopp
Byrd on on Reddit says, So my kid and I were
at the store tonight to pick up a few groceries
when this lady approached us and said politely,
excuse me.
And to be honest, I thought she was going
to ask me for help or asked me where something
was.
I was about to say, I don't work here, lady.
When she asked me why we were wearing masks,
that's when I realized she wasn't wearing
one.
I started walking away while replying because
of the Delta variant and also because there's
a mandate.
Then she went on about how she was born and
raised here in Nebraska.
And it's too bad some Nebraskans have turned
into sheep.
She asked if I've had a vaccine and said that
my kid and I don't need to wear masks because
we look young and healthy.
There were several other people around wearing
masks, but for some reason she chose to pick
on me and my kid.
At the end of the video, some poor guy working
there tries to intervene and basically told
us all just go our separate ways.
Karen walked away and I told the guy what
happened.
He said it wasn't the first time he's had
to deal with people like her at work.
I tried to continue my shopping, but the lady
followed me around the store.
I told her she needs to keep her distance
and her coughing on me was assault.
She kept laughing and saying, look at you.
It's so cute how scared you are.
By this time I was absolutely livid, trying
my best to hold it together in front of my
kid.
I didn't finish my shopping.
I instead went to the self checkout to pay
for my stuff.
She followed me to use the checkout right
next to me.
I informed the employee manning the checkout.
This woman assaulted me by coughing deliberately,
but I didn't wait around to see what the employee
would say.
So let's take a look at this video.
This this is horrifying.
And what's horrifying about it is it's less
about the specific risk of contagion, but
it's that there are people in our country
who would do this and who think that they
are making some kind of prescient point by
doing this.
All right.
Let's take a look.
Let's take a listen.
Unidentified: If you excuse me, I'm coming
through.
Speaker 1: So this is a disgusting person.
But is she also mentally ill?
I don't know.
I mean, you know, normal people don't behave
this way, but even that term normal has become
very loaded and covid times and.
Unidentified: She's coughing out No.
You guys are so.
OK, whatever your.
Why don't you have a laugh, because I don't
need to have one on.
And neither are you.
You don't know this
Speaker 1: trick or not.
I my allergy, you know, Chernoff, by the way,
how annoying are those fake coughs and
Speaker 2: how you got.
Yeah.
And so two years ago, before everybody started
talking about covid, you were OK with going
out, not knowing you were.
Right.
You don't want my help.
I don't.
Yeah, she's happy now.
I have the energy and she got all freaked
out.
I'm confused.
You don't know she's here?
No, don't.
No, she just said I don't know anything about
her.
You don't know anything about my health.
I actually maybe I have a medical, OK,
Speaker 1: medical, but I don't know if you
might have a medical care.
And now.
Unidentified: OK, the.
You have got hands and so, OK,
Speaker 1: so I think you get the point now,
there were some people saying call the police
next time, but one user on the Reddit post
about this had called the police this time,
which I agree with.
There is video evidence of of a crime being
committed.
OK, what crime?
We were looking into this.
And it seems as though in Nebraska, this is
assault in the third degree.
This is Nebraska revised statute twenty eight
three one zero assault in the third degree.
A person commits the offense of assault in
the third degree if he intentionally, knowingly
or recklessly caused his bodily injury to
another person or threatens another in a menacing
manner.
Assault in the third degree shall be a class
one misdemeanor unless committed in a fight
or scuffle entered into by mutual consent,
in which case it should be a class two misdemeanor.
So that's the most likely thing.
The other idea that's been floated is that
coughing coronavirus coughing attacks might
be able to be prosecuted as terrorism.
And this is an article from What is the date?
This is from April of 2020 when these coughing
incidents started where Nikita Malik, a contributor
to Forbes, wrote that covid-19 is considered
a biological agent, meaning that if you deliberately
cough on a policeman or merchandise, which
was what was going on at the time, you could
be charged with terrorism.
I think, you know, it's probably a stretch
to get a conviction on that.
But at least there's the idea that it could
be we do need to throw the book at these people.
This is not, you know, when we talk about
anti-social behavior detrimental to all of
society where culturally, from a health standpoint,
from any aspect, you want to look at this
not taking seriously people who go out and
to make some kind of political point, I don't
even know what it is or because they're just
out of their minds or a combination of the
two are coughing during a pandemic on people
to scare them.
Right.
It's got to be taken as seriously as the law
allows.
So I am all for if you if you can do a terrorism
charge, do it.
If this is assault in the third degree under
Nebraska law, go with it.
But the people have to call the police.
And I understand that this woman wrote, I
just wanted to get out of there.
I'm not blaming her for that.
But let's all come together and say that if
we see this stuff, let's make every effort
to actually get police involved and really
make sure that these people, even if they
don't get convicted, have to spend months
dealing with the justice system because of
the disgusting thing that they did.
We'll have more more on this particular incident
on the show Instagram.
You can find us on Instagram at David Pakman
show.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be
right back.